はい 心の汚れと無知を始末する
最終的にはそういう始末に入ります
仏教は外の世界の品物を敵扱いも味方扱いもしません
今まで品物の話でしたけど
仏教にしてみればそんなのはどうでもいいんです
品物は 敵でも味方でもないんです
どうったことないんです
問題は自分の無知 心の問題なんですね
無知で起きた勘違い 苦しみでできているもろい命を守るために必死になることは勘違いの結果です
我々は必死で生きていきたいんですよ
死にたくないんです あれっていうのは
ちょっとした勘違いの結果なんです
期待は期待通りにいかないんです
死にますし また輪廻もするんです
守っても無常たる命は守れませんので
努力は水の泡になるんです
必死で努力しているでしょ
死に物狂いで努力しているでしょ
すべて水の泡になるんです
苦があるからこそ 物に依存させているのです
なんで我々は宝石が好きはカバンは欲しいわ
あれやこれやとか いろんなものを欲しいかと
苦があるんだからなんですよ
あれで苦が消えると思っているんです
生きる苦が しかし これが本来の苦に無限に苦を加える行為です
生きることは苦 楽しくない
その方がブランドのカバン欲しいから
それやったら楽しいと
楽しくならないんです
さらに新しい苦が増えるだけ
だから物が欲しいと思ってのは
生きることは苦だから
それで物が取ることによって
生きる苦がどんどん増えて増えていくんです
どんどん奴隷になっていくんです
ですから 問題は心にある
生存欲 恐怖 怒りなどの汚れがあるから心が苦しんでいるんです
生存欲なかったらね 脆い命にそんなに必死にならないんですよ
だから心に問題があるんです
それはものが解決してくれません
死にたくない人が何食べても死ぬんですよ
物は解決しません また
物に幸福がないんです
これもすごい勘違いですよ
物に幸福があると ないんです
それ気持ちなんですよ
物を得た人は幸福だと思わないなら不幸です
でお正月するね もう鏡餅とかいろいろ飾ってあって
ああ お正月で幸せだなとかいう気分になると幸せなんです
うるさいな またお正月だから
あれやこれややりくりやらなこっち行かないんだ
しち面倒くさいだと思ったらしち面倒くさいんです
鏡餅置いたんだからといって
みんな幸せになるわけじゃないんです
だから物にないんです
幸せが お金もらったら
あ お金もらったのは幸せや
では友達一緒に食べましょうとかね
じゃあみんなでみんなみんなにいろいろお世話になりましたから
今度は私が恩返ししますからとかね
そういう喜んでみんなでお祝いする人もいて
あれ これはあいつらにわからないように隠しておこうと
わかったら私からお金もらう
もうちょうだいと言うかもしれません
というふうに どんぞこ苦労になる人もいるんです
それはお金のせいじゃないんです
人の心の問題なんです
だから物に幸福はないということを覚えておいてください
いくら神社からお守り買ってきたってもね
そのものには幸福がないんです
えーと 心は本来無知で苦しんでいるから幸福だと感じないんです
心は だから いくらものを溜めても
心は幸福だと感じないんです
だって 豊かな人であっても
いっぱい品物を持っている人であっても
幸せを感じないんです
足らない足らないだけは感じるんです
足らない もっと欲しいとは感じるんです
だからなおさら悪いんですよ
心次第で ものを見て幸福になることも
不幸になることもできるんだけど
本来何が起きるかというと
いくら物があっても不幸を感じるんです
心はそうなっているんです
心の病を解決することで
すべては始末になります
切望している幸福にも安定にも達します
我々は人生もろいだから安定したいんですよ
みんな安定した職業を探す
安定するために自分のマイホームを探す
安定するために結婚する
結婚生活を安定するために子供を作るとかね
みんな安定を目指してますよ
得られません その絶望していることに達します
心の問題解決すれば 価値観を見直す必要があります
それに価値観を見直してほしい
苦無常無我である現象に価値は成り立ちません
だから価値がない 価値があるではなくて
価値が成り立ちません
という言葉です この言葉の使い方
ちょっと厳しいんです
イエスノーの世界じゃないんです
ダイヤに価値がありますか？あります
いや ない どちらでもないんです
価値が成り立ちません
価値がないと発見するというのは成り立たないとね
捨てたことになってます
それだけでも捨てたことになってます
わざわざと物を持って重いものを捨てるという物理的な行為じゃないんです
仏教の捨て方は 価値が成り立ちませんよとも納得するんです
だから物があっても知らないようなのはと
私に関係ないと という執着の世界が現れるんです
物を拾うことでも 捨てること
正しいんですか？捨てることでも成り立たないんです
本来はこの両方も不可能です
持っているつもりと捨てたつもりです
我々は物を持っているつもり
あるいは捨てたつもり
持つこともできないし
捨てることもできないんです
何様ですかね 自分が物を捨てたと
初めから自分のものではなかったんですけど
自分の考え 思考 感情 自分の体は瞬間に変わるから
ものを得られないんです
考えが変わるんだから
体変わるんだからね 例えば
こちらにいる私は あちらにいる何かある
何か欲しくなるんです
それでここからあそこまで行くと
私の思考 考え 体 すべて変化しているんです
別の人になっているんです
だから別人 それは取ったってもね
こちらにいる私が取ったことにならないんですね
物も無常なので得ることは不可能です
そこであちらにあるものは
私はこちらで見てほしいと思っても
ここからあちらで行く間でそこを変化しているんです
別なものになっているんです
で 得られないんです 真理を知ると
ただ心の執着が消える
それで終わりです 心に執着が消える
それで全て 物と戦わないんです
仏教は はい それで話も終わりと思います
はい 長い時間になりましたけど
これで話を終わります
どうもありがとうございます